as we continue we are in Cedar Rapids
Iowa with the 45th and possibly 47th
president of the United States Donald
Trump is with us
you know we had this whole issue of
cocaine in the White House
okay
um I could only imagine what the
reaction would have been on then the
media and and with others about this and
here's what bothers me about it they had
a 10-day investigation they have a
cameras on every single person that
walked into that area they didn't
interview a single person and after 10
days they declared the investigation is
over we don't know who did it now
what's your reaction to that
so I know the era very well it's very
private actually in a true sense and
they probably have more care first there
was three different locations yeah well
they don't even know what location and
they also said the bidens weren't there
and they were there it turned out to be
you know false a lot of false reporting
a lot of misinformation they Diss and
Miss information right nobody's ever
explained the difference but let's
assume they're pretty close uh you have
more cameras in that area than any place
probably in the world you have the
Situation Room The Situation Room I
never even thought of it in terms of
this but probably the most important
room anywhere in the world it's no more
important Wars are decided nuclears
decided weapons are decided it's been
there there's nothing more important
they have cameras that's where you
decided to take out solomoni that's
where you decided to take out baghdadi
and Associates right defeat Isis don't
forget we defeated Isis I was told it
would take three to four years to defeat
Isis that we probably couldn't do it I
did it in four weeks less than four
weeks right and took out took out the
worst
but the situation room is very heavily
guarded they know who is they know
everything the other thing I have a
great respect for Secret Service I deal
with them all the time they are really
incredible people
and Secret Service knows what's
happening they know what's happening so
I think it's very disappointing that
after just a few days I was over that's
a big deal cocaine now the cocaine as
they say could have been worse they
could have gone to the the bio weapons
they could have gone to a lot of other
things but cocaine's pretty bad if
somebody's taking cocaine and making
decisions what if there was fentanyl in
it what if it was Anthrax well it could
have been a lot of I forbid it could
have been a lot of things and they have
cameras and I would imagine it doesn't
stop here but Secret Service is so
incredible they don't get enough enough
credit and they're under the orders of
other people but I think Secret Service
would be able to tell you the real
answer but you can't have a thing like
that the most embarrassing thing for our
country we were respected three years
ago this country was respected and Putin
knew he couldn't do it and president XI
of China knew he couldn't you know I
gave Iowa and foreign Farmers the farm
farm States 28 billion million dollars
from China 28 billion that's why I said
you know I go around
I don't want to be too uh boisterous on
this because you never know right but I
said there's no way I can lose Iowa and
Nebraska any of these states there's no
way because I gave the farmers 28
billion dollars from China no person no
president has ever gotten 10 cents from
China I got hundreds of billions of
dollars and I went to the secretary of
agriculture how much has I think they
obviously got
thank you I love you too I will tell you
that but think of President XI Central
Casting brilliant guy you know when I
say is brilliant everyone says oh that's
terrible you call it well he runs 1.4
billion people with an iron fist smart
brilliant everything perfect there's
nobody in Hollywood like this guy I got
them to pay us 28 billion dollars
because they screwed our Farmers for
years and I had the secretary of
agriculture come up and I said give me a
number they said it's 28 billion dollars
comes back a week later it's 28 billion
dollars I said that's a lot I said well
we're going to take it from China I got
28 billion dollars for the farmers who
got a check did everybody get
and
I also made the usmca we had the worst
trade deal that we ever made NAFTA you
get killed on NAFTA and I made it the
best trade deal the usmca it's a fan
that's Mexico and Canada I got billions
and billions of dollars from Japan and
other countries that were taking
advantage you couldn't sell into did
that money help pay for the wall uh let
me tell you what paid for the wall what
really helped Mexico was great you know
they all say Mexico Mexico paid much
more than what I was asking for because
I had 28 000 soldiers on the border when
I was building the wall and we built
almost 500 miles of wall and you know
our opponents you know what they say if
there's a little rotted out two by four
laying on the ground that's been there
for 50 or 60 years and you could they
would say when we build a 30 and 40 foot
wall oh that's just a renovation that's
not included we built almost 500 miles
of wall we renovated a lot then I said
let's build another 200 miles because
there were some areas that were weak and
it was all there ready to be installed
and they didn't doing but Mexico I said
to the president you have to do me a
favor you have to do us a favor we need
28 000 soldiers on the border Mexican
soldiers he laughed at me and you know I
have a very good relationship with him
but he said but why would we do that
because they're coming in through Mexico
you have to stop them from coming in
from Mexico they're coming in in
Caravans he said we can't do that then
he had a representative come to see the
state department person the state
department person said you know I've
been doing this for years we've always
asked for a lot of different things like
remain in Mexico I got remain in Mexico
past nobody thought it was possible all
of the different
Catch and Release how about this you
catch a criminal and you release him
into the United States okay I got catch
everything but I got this and they said
to me we won't do it we won't do it they
smiled they left they said what are you
are you crazy we wouldn't do this I said
yes you'll do it because if you don't do
it we're going to put a 25 tax on all of
your cars coming in from Mexico and
you're going to do it we're going to
take in billions of dollars and we'll do
it ourselves
so Mexico gave us billions of dollars of
free soldiers free of charge you know
they came back into the room after
saying actually sort of laughing at me
how stupid a question this was they said
you think we're not going to do that I
said yes you will you'll do that he said
we're not going to do that and I said
well we're putting a tariff on all of
your products including all the cars in
your store because you know they have 32
percent of our car business left for
Mexico I said we're going to put a third
we're going to put a tariff 25 it's
going to go higher but 25 take in
billions he said man leave the room
please yes he comes back five minutes
later we would be honored to give you 28
000. so Mexico Mexico paid plenty let me
go back to the China issue
we think of all the incidents we had the
Chinese spy balloon that you know went
from the Skies of Alaska down to Idaho
across to Montana it's Kansas Missouri
Kentucky out the coast the east coast
and I look at the Communist Chinese now
confronting our Navy ships in
international waters confronting our
fighter jets and international airspace
on top of intellectual property theft on
top of covid-19 on top of unfair Trade
Practices devaluation of the dollar I
believe attempts to eliminate the U.S
dollar as the world they want to do that
they're working hard and now they've
aligned with Russia and Iran
and now they're negotiating and North
Korea and North Korea now the
negotiating deals between the Saudis and
the Iranians and the Saudis and the
syrians now I think China is taking
advantage of a president that has
abdicated his role as the most dominant
America being the most dominant force on
the world would they have ever done that
under you and how would you have
permitted it number one they wouldn't
have done it number two if they did it I
would have said excuse me we're going to
put a 100 tariff on all of your goods
that are coming into the United States
and they would have backed up up
immediately you know I took in hundreds
of billions of dollars from China and as
I said not one president for many
presidents ever took in anything you
know they revered China I don't know I
also explained hey we all love China
Let's Love China let's respect the
president let's respect everybody but
they took advantage of the United States
making hundreds of billions of dollars a
year we built their military because
they made so much money I took in
hundreds of billions of dollars from
China you think Taiwan is going to get
invaded well I think they have no
respect for Biden they have no respect
whatsoever for them it would have never
happened I met with Putin and I said
listen if you do this really really bad
things are going to happen to Russia and
I don't want to say because I'm not
going to get into that but I said really
bad things he said no no no you would
never do that I said yes I would and he
said I don't like that but you know
maybe you didn't believe it but he
believed it five percent or ten percent
that that's all they need I said bad
thing said the same thing to president
XI I had a great relationship with
frankly both of them and you know having
a good relationship with these guys
they're smart tough and they have a lot
of nuclear weapons having a good
relationship I tried to explain this to
the fake news that's a good thing not a
bad thing there is no bit nobody's been
rough on Russia like I have I'm the one
that ended Nordstrom too Nordstrom 2 is
the big pipeline going into Germany and
all over here I ended it
that's the worst thing that any
president or anybody has ever done to
Russia I ended their Pipeline and the
money that and Putin said to me how
could you do that I ended it and Biden
came in and he approved it I put
sanctions in I gave the javelins which
are anti-tank Busters I gave the
javelins to Ukraine when they took out
all those tanks that was from Trump you
know what Obama you know when they say
oh Trump trump was good to Russia I was
the worst thing that ever happened but I
still got along with Putin and he
respected me and I got along with she
and respected our country they no longer
respect our country okay you have said
very boldly you could end this Ukrainian
Russia war in 24 hours how so I know
zelinski very well because he was very
honorable with the fake phone call
impeachment hoax number one they said I
made a phone call to him and I was very
threatening I wasn't at all I was
actually very nice I was congratulating
him a victory but when they asked him
they said do did you were you threatened
he didn't even know what they were
talking about he was very honorable he
could have done grandstand he said I
felt threatened I felt threatened he
didn't do that and as you know I get
along very well with Putin I would tell
Putin got a settle I would tell zelinski
you gotta settle I would tell one you're
gonna load up with money I tell the
other you're not gonna get any money I
would get a settlement in 24 hours now
it should have never happened you have
thousands hundreds of thousands of dead
people right now hundreds of thousands
who have cities that are obliterated I
don't know if you've ever seen the
cities after they finish with the
Rockets you have cities with no building
standing it looks like just a demolition
Zone it's so horrible sad and you know
and then they'll say two people were
hurt no hundreds of people and thousands
of people were killed you're going to
find out when this whole thing is over
that the number of people killed is far
greater than they tell you they're not
telling you the truth many many
thousands hundreds of thousands of
people are dying these cities are being
obliterated and basically they say
what's your stance are you for Russia or
you've I'm for one thing very simple I
want to stop people from getting killed
and I'll have it stop fast take a break
we'll come back up next
we'll talk about the 2024 primary and
one big question is the Biden family
with their business dealings with China
and Russia and Romania and Ukraine and
Kazakhstan and Mexico and a dozen other
countries
are they compromised more with Donald
Trump on the other side straight ahead
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else